now whomever is nominated to be the next
homeland security secretary will have to
be approved by the Senate it is very
hard to get anything done on Capitol
Hill these days as shown in the new book
the hill to die on the battle for
Congress and the future of trumps
America Politico reporters Jake Sherman
and Anna Palmer wrote the book together
they have each covered Capitol Hill for
nearly a decade in this book is the
result of 26 months of reporting the
interviewed senators House members White
House aides and President Trump
good morning good morning not only is it
full of information it's a juicy read
but first let's talk about the news
secretary Nielsen resigning who will be
her replacement and how hard will it be
to get that person confirmed very
difficult to get the person confirmed I
think that we know for a fact people
have mentioned Rick Perry but Donald
Trump seems to like acting secretaries
at the moment he believes that they have
he has more control over them and they
don't get too comfortable in the job
which is something as you noted we've
seen a dozen cabinet secretaries leave
so it's something he likes and they
don't have to get confirmed right which
is the key he also seems to like chaos
as you point out in your book he likes
to stir things up and keep everybody off
balance Anna yeah absolutely I mean I
think you saw him tweeting last night
about this I mean he's hard on the
border he likes to kind of almost like
he's a Hollywood producer right he's
changing the cast midstream when he
doesn't think something is working out
for him this is what you guys say about
Congress it's unlike any other
institution on earth a remarkable place
of democracy but one of the pettiest
collections of adults and teenage
melodrama for instance Jake well there
are I think you could look from the top
I mean I think Paul Ryan former speaker
Paul Ryan who left at the end of this
congressional term had a lot of problems
with Donald Trump yet got on his side I
mean think about it this way Congress is
535 former high school class presidents
yeah and I think that's only been
aggravated or accentuated in Donald
Trump's Washington where you have a
unpredictable chief executive who calls
people at all hours of the night ringing
up members of Congress and all hours
asking for their advice and it's really
a picture of chaos yeah let me ask you
about that because President Trump when
he ran for president said I'm a
dealmaker I know how to negotiate things
I have a special quality never before
seen in why
shetan to get people to come to the
table and i may knock their heads
together or cajole them but I'm gonna
get things done in practice he's made a
lot of phone calls tells me has chummy
moments but does he have the talent has
he applied the skill to actually get
anything done in the hard business of
actually getting things done I think he
doesn't deserve a very good grade right
if he looked at the first two years
which this book really details from
Election Day 2016 through the midterm
through the shutdown he really only had
one bright spot which was tax reform and
even tax reform which we detail was a
partisan issue if they did not do it
with any Democrats so yes the president
likes to say he's a deal maker but truly
he has not brought Democrats to the
table to do anything really substantive
I'm fascinated with the relation you
want to say so just I would just add to
this that we were given really amazing
access President Trump as we all know
proclaims to not like the media but
members of Congress are very very eager
to talk to president we have we had
members of Congress allow us in meetings
we traveled with them around the country
we listened to their phone calls we had
recordings of their meetings their
emails their memos so we were really
able to bring our readers inside of the
process of DC I'll say a couple of times
of when I was reading the book I thought
did people know you were there but
apparently they did because it was to
Nora's word juicy I'm fascinated by
Nancy Pelosi and Donald Trump he seems
to be fascinated with her - you said
that Pelosi is Trump's polar opposite
what way what do you mean yeah I mean if
you look at if Donald Trump loves chaos
Nancy Pelosi loves order that's right uh
you know I think one of the things
that's very interesting is the reverence
and respect that the president gives
Nancy Pelosi it is unlike any other
member or figure when we talked to him
and sat down with him when he was
describing his relationship with members
of Congress clearly Pelosi is the steady
hand in Washington she is the person who
has the most power and control and is
going to be the adult in the room her
nickname is Nancy that says something
and I think also on top of that she
doesn't back down from the president she
stares him in the eye and says this is
where I'm going this is what I want to
do and the president then is forced to
back down as we saw with the government
shutdown President Trump didn't get his
border wall in Nancy Pelosi one you also
detail Sean Hannity at Fox News being on
a number of calls to those on the other
end of the call know that he's also on
the call
Yatta anything here to weigh here at
home there were moments where he ways in
which we detail but I think it was
surprising to both of us
how involved Sean Hannity was not just
tweeting and maybe having conversations
just with the president but how involved
he was on a more regular basis I mean we
saw people leaving meetings on Capitol
Hill picking up their cell phone and
it's Sean Hannity calling me we saw this
firsthand so this isn't konjac what does
that say to you all that he is that
involved what does that mean it's it's
it's unlike anything we've ever seen in
our in our times covering Washington for
a TV talk Coast to have such sway over
the President of the United States is
unusual all right the hill to die on is
on sale now Jake Sherman and Palmer
thank you so much for being with us